hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the interplay of today's
abroad profiling and phenotypic
screening I am Christina mahalik of lab
roots calm and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab reefs calm and
sponsored by discover X discover a
corporation headquartered in fremont
california if the leader in design
manufacture and sale of biochemical and
style based assays for the drug
discovery and life science market for
today's drug discovery the center x
offers the largest collection of nearly
500 biochemical and Saliva's kinase
assays genome scan discover x's novel
kinase inhibitor binding platform
includes an industry-leading set up
kinase assays that allow rapid
determination of km wide compound
potency in selectivity keynotes camp
together with discover X cell based
services can be applied to all stages of
drug discovery and are ideal for
identifying potent and selective
inhibitors you can learn more at
discover XCOM we have a few for the
announcements before we begin today this
is a web webcast it is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can do
this by submitting your questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can today
additionally you can enlarge the sliding
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window and if you have any technical
problems hearing or viewing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or
submit your problem tore the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
window this is an educational web
seminar and this offers free continuing
education credit after the webinar is
over please Chris on the Cee button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credit now I would
like to introduce today's speaker Edgar
jakoby PhD senior principal scientist in
computational chemistry jenison research
and development Edgar Jacobi holds a
license in Sciences chamak from the Don
and dr. rear unnatural iam in
computational chemistry from the r WTH
ahem after both postdoctoral work in
molecular biophysics at harvard medical
school and the university of chicago
he's joined a sir ba in 1995 as cadre de
rue share fav molecular modeling in 1999
he joined the combinatorial chemistry
group and Novartis central technologies
as web head for the in silico design of
combinatorial compound libraries from
2002 to 2012 he led the molecular in
library informatics group from the
Novartis center / manama Kenneth
chemistry in algal in 2013 he joined
jansen research and develop advanced
development in bears as senior principal
scientist in computational chemistry I
will now turn it over to dr. Jacobs for
his presentation dr. Jacob e the floor
is yours thank you very much miss Donna
for the kind introduction and invitation
to speak at his seminar so you know
candidates have been the last decade
amongst the most successful targets with
sales around 250 billion dollars over
the last five years and have been
approached by target feminity discovery
methodologies here I will speak about
three projects in the eye
of interplay of Chinese profiling and
phenotypic screening so project one will
provide detailed on the anson kinase
inhibitor profiling project which is
integral part of the eunjin canis drug
discovery strategy project 2 is
unfinished screening activities of our
potent and selective kinase inhibitor
set we did from 2014 2 2016 in
collaboration with Dundee University and
project 3 is about work done in within
the European I am I open facts consult
zoom where we showed how a semantically
integrated data platform is useful for
annotation of energy big hit compounds
so now I have to change so kinase
inhibitor profiling is part of the young
santana's drug discovery strategy
motivation for the projects where the
kinase inhibitor broad profiling would
enable us to capitalize on existing
chemical assets to identify hits for new
projects to identify probe compounds for
target identification and validation to
prioritize biochemical versus cell-based
assay development and to link to chemo
genomic and system based approaches at
the beginning of the can is inevitable
profiling project we had to answer two
key questions first question was which
compound profiling platform to select
there are a number of possibilities here
which are outlined in this slide they
differ by the number of Chinese discover
the SI type format sell various
biochemical the construct type or the
ATP concentration used in the essay so
we selected discover external scan
platform which has broad coverage
including mutants Kadam scan is a
competitive binding essay which allows
the determination of kds after chain
proof of correction the essay use
affinity beads to immobilize DNA target
kinases which are displaced by the test
compound in a dose-dependent manner
the kinase concentration is then dozed
using qpcr reaction desi allows some
multiplexing and is available for more
than 400 wild-type karnazes and mutants
the second key question was about the
selection of the compounds which
compounds should be profile so youngson
has around 77,000 kinase a winter
compounds which were synthesized within
40 internal kinase projects of
unkindness focus library enhancement
projects a medicinal chemistry guided
selection was done for 3,000 compounds
in addition to include selection from
cheminformatics based approaches prior
to the project we have profiled around
8,000 compounds in discover X and
millipore essays so that after the
completion of the project we had brought
profiling data for around 11,000
compounds the chemical structure
diversity of the two thousand eleven
thousand and 77,000 sets are shown in
the stochastic proximity embedding map
shown in the slide the 3000 compound set
covers the chemical space broadly and
there are some areas clusters which are
more densely populated having available
the full matrix of 3369 compounds and
396 white type can eases with
displacement efficacy values determined
in single point measurements at one
micromolar compound concentration of
first type of analysis was about a
kinase space covered with potent and
selective inhibitors using the activity
vector of a given compound one can
calculate the s65 selectivity measure
which is the number of kinase compounds
hits with displacement efficacy greater
than sixty-five percent divided by the
total number of Chinese is tested the
s65 value gives the fraction of the hit
kaindl in approximation
we define that a given compound cover
the kinase if it hits the kindness with
displacement efficacy greater than
ninety five percent and has an x 65
value below the threshold of 2.5 five
and ten percent respectively these are
the three curves you see in this plot
the plot shows the kinase coverage
independence of the fraction of the
kinase library screened doing this we
observe three things the coverage allows
asymptotic dependence on the compound
library size the coverage is hi gher
with less selective compounds at 65 it's
ten percent is the top curve and 4s 65
equals five percent one levels off
around 275 karnazes with the full three
thousand compound set and further
extension rate is around 20 to 30
kindnesses with thousand compounds in
the next step we had to select the
compounds for the confirmation kdd
elimination round to this aim we
selected around 3500 compound kinase
interactions for KD determination
obviously we wanted to focus on the most
potent and selective compounds and also
impact discovery projects of immediate
interest from the 3500 dose response
curve we observe a 51-percent
confirmation rate grouping the data in
selectivity and efficacy bins as shown
in the table allows a number of inside
as expected compounds with higher
primary displacement efficacy have
higher confirmation rates vertical
reading for each selectivity bin to our
surprise we observe that more
promiscuous compounds have a higher
confirmation rate horizontal reading of
the table the most selective compounds
confirm poorly to understand this we
know that a false positive rate of a
typical
items can sa is around one to two
percent that is if one screens DMSO and
singer concentration experiments one
expects to hit up to ten kinase 'as we
then selected based on 11,000 compounds
we had screened in all our essays the
potent and selective inhibitors and
analyzed the candies coverage using both
ic50 data for the millipore data and KD
data for the discovery x data doing this
we have 434 compounds with IC 50 / kds
below 10 nano Mora and s65 below five
percent which have 129 kinases relaxing
the potency criteria 200 nanomolar we
find that we have 1257 compounds with
ic50 KD below ha at nanomolar and s65
below five percent which covered 257
karnazes we see that we cover the kind
of trees quite uniformly and with
sundered nanomolar compounds we cover
branches not covered before in the 10
nano molar 3 in the next step we
compared to kinase covered by the anson
compounds through the kinase covered in
the idol gene certainty kinase knowledge
base which is published and patented
kinase inhibitors in total there are 331
Canada's which can be considered to be
covered there are 96 candidates which
uniquely are covered by the young sunset
and this underlines the added value of
the profiling experiment this slide
shows how the anson kinase inhibitor
profiling project positively impacted in
the last two years discovery project
teams the impact has for instance we've
seen in the identification of potential
chemical starting points the
confirmation of hds it's
delivery of two compounds for essays the
prioritization of compounds for hds
based on selectivity the prioritization
of essay formats for hds the validation
stage d validation of targets the
generation of ideas for covalent design
and the initiation of new projects so
this work has been summarized in a drug
discovery today feature article which
you can read to find out more detail the
next project I will report on is on the
phenotypic screening of our kinase
inhibitor set we did with the dundee
dset consortium we screened our
selective important kinase inhibitor set
on typical phenotypic assays running in
Dundee dsdt biology labs and one essay
in collaboration with Greg print lay
will be hand light highlighted the
essays is exploring the control of
embryonic stem cell proponents see the
principle of the essay illustrated in
the following slide now even prime prova
potency stem cells in a dynamic
equilibrium which can be switched to the
one or other side using any bidders of
specific kinases for each state
expression markers are identified the
naive red state is marked by Na Nog and
KF na for proteins the pliant blue state
is marked by the dnmt3b protein fgfr
activity switched naive state to the
primed state fgfr any bidders that shift
the equilibrium to the naive red state
vice versa Jack activity switched the
prime stage to the naive state jak
inhibitors are currently shift
equivalent to the primed blue state
the objective of the kinase inhibitor
screening is to identify new kindnesses
which potentially direct the equivalent
to the one or other side to analyze the
results we wanted to emphasize the usage
of the primary profiling data we have
generated with a broad profiling
experiment in the signature analysis
outlined here the primary data matrix is
binarized according to an activity
threshold zero meaning inactive below
the threshold one meaning active above
the threshold in the next step the
number of active compounds are counted
for each kinase the kinase with the
highest number of hits are suggested
assets in the in the assignment of the
candies for divinity big screen we now
have in place more sophisticated
protocols which analyzed the enrichment
of the hits versus the baseline of all
compounds including the inactives the
results are comparable but I'm not shown
here he had the results of the signature
analysis four hits identifying to drive
the naive state both the discoveries and
millipore matrixes we analyzed by
signature analysis separately according
to the analysis hits driving the naive
state red states are fgfr fleet for and
fleet one or let inhibitors hits driving
the primed blue state I inhibitors of
medically three these kinds are now
recommended for further experiments
using for instance respect asinine
validation experiments the next slide
illustrates potential application of the
stemness biology potential applications
in the cancer fields are to evaluate
development of naive process primate and
differentiated states or in the
regenerative medicine filled the ex vivo
reprogramming of stem cells followed by
directed differentiations to what
specialized
cell types with potential applications
in Alzheimer's disease diabetes or
cancer in the last part of my talk I
will show a few computational protocols
for phenotypic hit annotation and in
city code target deconvolution which
were developed within the European IMI
open fax consortium the IMI open fax
consortium run from 2011 2016 and had
aim to explore the capabilities of
semantic web based discovery platform
using open data the headline of the year
presented protocols is knowing the
knowns about the hits which come out
affinity big screen protocol one
provides kb campbell annotations and
classification of hit lists protocol
tool provides the go annotation the
genome ontology annotation for the
proteins for which interactions unknown
based on protocol one protocol three
provides the wiki pathways annotations
for the proteins protocol for provides
the link to disease and possible side
effect for the proteins which are hit
and portable 5 provides a correlation
between phenotypic and biochemical
screening data protocol 6 identify the
compound toolbox to validate d validate
identified potential targets of protocol
one based on the IFR reference database
such annotation capabilities are made
possible by the semantic integration
among key data concepts which were
integrated in open sites using the
campbell data the known compound target
interactions are identified the compound
data is directly linked to the compound
classification data in kebbi and the
target data is directly linked to go
pathway and disease data and the
campbell target classification the next
slide illustrates the correlation robert
protocol implemented in pipeline pilot
data pipeline software from biovea in
more detail
Python pilot allows the seamless access
to the open fax API calls the essential
public planet nodes corresponding to the
API calls have been programmed in the
project what you see here in step 1 top
data stream organisms from the kinase
Kimball canister ER put using the target
class member list call in step 2 second
line the essay data for example pre lame
in a surprising corrector essay is
pulled using the target pharmacology
list hole in step 3 we pull for each
kinase of the kinase 3 the available
pharmacology data using the target
pharmacology list call and step for
dusty correlation itself in the shown
example we do the most simple
correlation type by just counting the
number of hits common to a sa pair here
more complex correlation functions can
be used when the data is less best like
for instance corporate screening data or
full HD s this slide 18 shows the
protocol to assemble a toolbox of known
reference compounds for the annotated
targets interacting with the phenotypic
hit compounds step 1 reads the IO fire
compound target into action file there I
you for database is a database of
reference compounds which are wet
studied in pharmacology and integrates
also compounds from the SGC structured
genomics probe initiative step 2 gets
for each annotated target uniprot ID of
the target using the target information
call step 3 does then the joining based
on uniprot ad the following steps are
generating the output format the result
is a list of compounds with link targets
which can be tested in the phenotypic
screen
this work also has been published in the
2016 met communication paper which
summarized the work done in the open
facts consortium on in city code target
validation and phenotypic speeding by
demonstrating the application of the
protocols on the pre lame in a splicing
character essay I wish to summarize the
seminar with a few conclusion statements
biochemical profiling of existing
proprietary kinase inhibitors allow to
jump start new projects and to impact
project decisions second the anthems
approach the worldís laboratory allows
to capitalize on our asset in a
fast-changing scientific environment
I've seen both in the kinome scan and
the dsdt projects insert the open facts
platform delivered useful computational
protocols for phenotypic screening and
data analysis finally I wish to not
acknowledge a number of colleagues who
have in this project which are shown
here on the acknowledgements slide thank
you much for you and tension thank you
so much for that informative
presentation dr. ajai debate before we
get started on the question and answer
session of them i would like to remind
our audience adam submit questions you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
once again we'll try to answer as many
questions as you can excellent alright
well let's get started with our first
question for the day um let's see dr.
jacobi how is today's drug discovery
evolving in an industry yeah so I said
initially that candidates have been in
the last ten years among the most
successful targets and there were very
big initiatives in industry
platforms kinase platforms and a number
of companies where systematically the
members of the candies family we
explored this has changed in the last
two or three years to situation where we
go less systematically but very
selectively pic kinase for which we have
disease relevant information and then
screen these and do drug discovery with
these so I in the last ten years I think
after GPCRs Canada's are the most
successful target family and it
continues to be of importance excellent
thank you for that answer will be moving
on to our second question and this
question asked the open fax project was
completed in 2016 how does the
sustainability plan look like yeah so
the open factor consortium was this
project sponsored by the IMI initiative
in Europe and after the completion of
the project the open fact Foundation
took over to continue the activity so
this is a foundation sponsored by
companies and which has a plan to
sustain the sustainability to guarantee
the sustainability of the infrastructure
which is developed it was developed in
the project now you have to see that a
number of startup companies have started
to rebuild also the platform which was
initially provided by open facts there
are companies like Orioles for example
who have semesta matically expanded data
integration providing now these services
excellent thank you for that our third
question is with the broad performing
screen it be beneficial to smaller set
of compounds such as a subset of a
library to in the paper library and it
is so how would you choose the compound
yeah so typically what we have done here
we have really tried to map the entire
chemical space we have available for
kinase and but we do also in projects in
specific kindness projects to
selectivity profiling here we talked
about to select sets of 200 to 300
compounds and then we go applying
medicine chemistry selection rewards
which are really based on selecting the
more interesting compounds from the
medicinal chemistry side meaning
compounds which have good solubility
good permeation and good exposure values
and then we want to know what is the
selectivity of these compounds so this
is the application in project which was
also mentioned in the beginning by the
introduction okay thank you so much for
that our next question asked as
described that maze inhibitor can have
potential application than treating
diseases like cancer please explain more
about it yeah so kinase is indeed
targets in oncology and and it's the
main application domain of kinase
inhibitors there are some indications
also in immunological diseases so candy
display very important roles as
modulator and signal transduction
pathways and this explains why they are
so prominent and why they influence in
teeth disease biology initially people
saw that kinda this would not be good
targets because of the selectivity but
then it was shown that indeed is
to design very selective compounds and
this then made it to this importance in
in drug discovery excellent thank you so
much for that information dr. Jacob is
the inclusion doesn't look like we have
any more questions for the day do you
want any closing comments that you would
like to leave with our audience yeah i
think in phenotypic screening and which
is probably the new wave of twin
directors called a new old wave of drew
in drug discovery it's very important to
have characterized compounds which we
can get with this profiling and also to
have informatics tools to to annotate
the knowledge which we have to these
compounds and then be able to have much
faster target identification validation
experiments then we had done before so i
think these platforms together this
information technology is very important
for phenotypic screening well thank you
so much for your time today dr. Jacobs I
like to thank you once again and I'd
also like to thank our sponsor discover
explore making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
June 2017 you will receive an email from
elaborate alerting you of when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you we encourage you to for that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event this is
Christina from lab reeks calm we hope to
see you here again soon thank you and
have a great day goodbye